this takes us to the last agenda item
for the plenary session of today and the
last agenda item just before the lunch
break the ftth Awards I hand over to
Ronan to deliver the winners of 2018
ftth Awards thank you or zibethinus it
now at this point that we use this
opportunity to give a little bit of a
sneak insight with regard to some of the
findings from our updated
fiber-to-the-home panorama am as most of
you know the fibre to home council we
don't just acknowledge individuals or
operators with our awards every year we
also give a very up-to-date snapshot
with regard to how the industry is
performing in general which countries
are doing particularly well and which
operators are doing well within those
countries and this year I picked out two
snippets from the overall findings which
will be presented tomorrow morning and
they they'll be presented at the 9:30
session in conference room to the full
findings but the snippets that I'm happy
to share with you at the moment first of
all is an update on the Spanish market I
thought it was appropriate given that
we're here and if we look at where the
spanish market has managed to get to as
of September of last year so remember it
is always a little bit of a lag in our
findings here but they've now got to the
point where they've got 17 and a half
million homes passed now at this stage
which i think is a fantastic achievement
and six million subscribers as well so I
think that deserves a round of applause
for the Spanish market is really an
outstanding achievement their
penetration rate is up there at 34% now
at this point so like if I look at some
of the more mature markets out there
particularly where you've got
infrastructure based competition they're
really getting up to those very high
penetration rates now across their
customer base so it's really really
encouraging and I think what it does
show I mentioned earlier when I gave the
keynote I spoke about going from zero to
hero in such a short period of time and
we also heard from the Minister as well
with regard to putting in place the
right policies and the right regulation
to allow that to happen and I think for
all of the other European countries too
lessons to be learned in that you know
we frequently hear people complain about
how difficult it is to roll out fibre
but it just shows when the right will is
in place when the right regulatory
environment is in place and when the
right environment for investors to
invest safely is in place you can't
achieve it and you can achieve it a lot
quicker than most people think the next
one which is one that's pretty close to
my heart and it's mutually a source of
pride but also a source of embarrassment
given my role within the
fiber-to-the-home Council and that is to
announce that Ireland has finally
managed to make it onto the panorama and
when I say make it onto the panorama by
way of reminder the the gating process
to get onto the panorama is your country
first of all must be a reasonable scale
so it must have at least two hundred
thousand households and then you need at
least one percent penetration of fibre
within the country so finally Ireland
now we've got three hundred thousand
homes passed thirty thousand of those
are connected so within the last year
they've gone from pretty much zero to
about a 10 percent penetration rate slow
start there is a lot of infrastructure
based competition there I think
organizations operators like the lights
of cyro who's a joint venture with
between Vodafone and the incumbent
electricity supplier have helped
catalyze the market we've seen in
response to that the likes of the
incumbent air also get on board I think
one of the challenges that we've got is
we've got a National Broadband Plan that
unfortunately is very badly broken we've
seen the withdrawal of sciro we've seen
the withdrawal of air from the process
there only is one remaining operator
involved in that process which is e NAT
I think most people are coming to the
conclusion that ultimately we need to
start that process all over again
because we don't really have what
represents competition so that's it from
me with regard to the the sneak preview
on the panorama for tomorrow you'll get
the full insights as I mentioned
tomorrow morning conference room 2 at
9:30 that brings us on to the awards
which is a very important part and I
want to talk about first of all the
individual award and the individual
award this year I'm delighted to have
the opportunity and to highlight really
what I would refer to is one of the
leading entrepreneurs in this space
they didn't start their business in a
shiny glass building they kind of remind
me very much of hewlett-packard where
they started out of a garage where in
this scenario they happen to start their
fiber-to-the-home business out of a barn
and it wasn't their first business in
that space they've been involved in a
couple of startups as well all related
to the fiber-to-the-home so it gives me
great pleasure to be able to announce
that this year's individual winner for
the fiber-to-the-home
award is Matthew hare CEO of Giggy clear
who's Matthew here come on down here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much round of applause
for Matthew our next award is our
operator award and I've delighted again
once again to have the opportunity to
give out this award the company that
we've awarded this year is has been
barely out of the news over the last 12
months for all the right reasons which
is nice for a change because quite often
the the press tend to focus in on
negativity and particularly when it
comes to building out fiber it felt like
every week that this company was
announcing a new area that they were
bringing their fiber network to and even
today there's no signs of that slowing a
vibrant young dynamic company which
connectivity goes hand in hand with
their innovation connectivity to them of
course is pure fibre to the home that's
their sole focus but innovation is also
core to their culture within the
organization their wholesale networks
are now increasingly breaking new ground
in the telecom sector and I think what
they've shown to a lot of the countries
across Europe is what can be achieved if
you focus in on wholesale open access
type networks it's my great pleasure to
announce that the Italian wholesale only
provider of open fiber is this year's
winner of the fiber-to-the-home council
operator award and here to collect the
award and trill to welcome on stage
Elizabeta Reaper the CEO of open fiber
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations again thank you very
well done just a couple of quick things
before we allow everybody to go for
lunch and first of all I want to draw
your attention to something that's very
close to the heart on the
fiber-to-the-home Council and in
particular the Board of Directors as
well and that is the ongoing support for
the promotion of greater equality within
our industry and particularly within the
fiber industry greater balance within
the industry and one of the initiatives
that we started with in the
fiber-to-the-home council is quite a few
years back now at this point and we've
continued at each each and every year to
support it is the whole women and fiber
initiative many of you will have seen
that the pop-up banners dotted around
the building and historically the women
in Fiber initiative was bringing
together the women that are involved in
our industry so that they could network
and build the strength of their their
their network together but this year
what we've just like t'do in consultant
in consultation with those that are
involved in it is to open that network
up much wider so this year's women and
fiber cocktail event which is at 5:30
this evening and that will be open to
all of the members all of it sorry all
of the attendees at the conference to
attend so it highly encourage you to
show your support for this very very
important movement we're seeing a lot of
change in every single industry across
the globe
it's critically important III think it
was the lady speaker earlier from orange
mentioned a figure of 15% which is
horrendous when you think about it you
know it's a we absolutely need to do
more to get more women involved in our
industry and bringing their ideas and
their innovations to bear the other
thing I'd like to draw your attention to
is don't forget tonight is vibration
noise and vibration night is that you
know when I listen to the feedback that
comes from all of the attendees of the
conference when we go through all the
surveys there's two key things that
stand out head and shoulders above all
of the others with regard to what drives
satisfaction from attending the event
the first thing is obviously the
workshops and everybody that I spoke to
over the last sort of 24 hours that
attended the workshops yesterday
reinforced that view that they continue
to be a source of excellent knowledge
but the other next most important thing
is the networking and I actively
encourage you we're coming up on
lunchtime now go network that's what
this event is all about but this evening
at the fibration night it's the perfect
opportunity to get to meet all of your
colleagues would and peers within the
industry and learn what they're doing
and how they're doing things differently
the final piece and I think apology I
probably should have been clicking here
but it wasn't um it doesn't matter I'll
keep talking and the final piece is just
by way of a reminder for next year we're
conscious that this year there were
challenges for people to overcome to
make it to the event we're conscious
there was multiple Hopf flights for a
lot of individuals and we're very
thankful for those that went to the
effort of traveling those distances
we're conscious that for many school
holidays were on this week which also
presented the challenge there was also
Valentine's Day which I'm sure many of
us got reminded as we walked out the
door to head for the conference that we
weren't going to be around for
Valentine's Day and that always presents
a challenge so we've put a lot of effort
in for next year's conference to ensure
that we're not conflicting with holidays
or personal hallmark type holidays
either and next year's conference is
moving to Rye and Amsterdam so from a
commute perspective I don't think we can
get it any more central than that I
think the vast majority of attendees
will be able to make it on either a
single hop flight or drive to it or take
the train to it so it's the perfect
location so we're really looking forward
to probably a record-breaking attendance
next year at the Rye event so with that
I'll wrap things up and let everybody go
for lunch Bon Appetit
you